kelly what's going on i have a 17 year
old son and he and his 16 year old
girlfriend are expecting a baby at the
end of next month
oh wow so it's right here huh
yes it is
yes it is i'm just trying to figure out
how to parent through this i've not been
doing a great job
and it's going to be here real soon
so how do i help support these kids
to the best of my ability i love that
you asked that question
and that you're vulnerable i really do
thank you for making this phone call
and for whatever it's worth if i look at
the data there's several hundred
thousand
parents across the country this year
they're going to be in your same
situation
and so you're helping out a lot of other
people too so thank you for making that
call
so when you say you haven't been doing a
good job what does that mean
well i'm just so confused as if i should
be
happy and excited and talking to these
kids like
in an exciting way or just trying to
prep them
and i know that they're getting a lot of
information just trying to prep them
steer them make sure that they're
doing well in school when doing what
they need to do
and um but then there's you know
it's like am i should i be excited or
should i be you know pounding on them
and just making sure they're doing what
they need to do
to graduate school i mean they're both
juniors and they still have one more
year of high school
so they're going to be living with one
of us
my son's dad and i are divorced and then
the
girls parents are still together but
it's like
maybe staying and how how do we do this
i love it okay so couple things are they
so they are gonna
continue some sort of romantic
relationship together
and raise this baby that's the goal yes
that is the goal okay
and they're going to move in with
either you or st
ex-husband or her parents
um we're not sure right now it sounds
like we're on a rotation
since my son goes back and forth between
his dad and myself yet
but i don't know that that's the
healthiest right it's not
yeah yeah okay okay so are you have you
sat down
and had some sort of
conversation some sort of connection
with her parents
a little bit mainly her mom
her dad's an alcoholic and um
but her mom seems super giddy very
excited
that she also is drowning in her own
problems
yep okay are they cool with her their
daughter
and their new grandbaby moving in with
you guys
i don't know that okay um we have not
really had that
discussion okay so and i don't know that
she really
could move in to either my home or
my ex-husband's i mean i probably have
the most space but at the same time
i have a lot of pets and the girl is
allergic to
a lot of things okay so so here's what
here's
i'm gonna give you a whole bunch of
stuff okay and if it gets too much to
write down
in fact i'll say don't write this down
you can circle back whenever this
um episode airs and then you can
pass it along to everybody involved here
and
this will give you some hey
this guy on the radio recommended that
we do some of these things together
and i want to follow that lead right so
i'm going to give you a
a a tip of spear here like a
a way to engage in these conversations
that might otherwise be a little bit
messy
but your your son and your new grandbaby
and your i don't even know what you
would call
her the the mother of your grandbaby
right because it's not going to be your
you know your daughter-in-law anything
yet they need
an adult to step up and help guide
what's coming
okay so to answer your original question
yes be as excited
and cheer this is a baby
i don't want your son welcoming in
a human being under a cloud of
negativity and regret
and they will need somebody to cheerlead
them to teach them how wonderful and
exciting and beautiful this new human
being is going to be
and they need somebody to help guide
them
on i mean the government just said a
year ago you can drive
right so they're still kids they're
still children
they need somebody else to help guide
them on
the responsibilities that they have no
idea are coming their way
right so it's a both and but if you lean
too heavy on
the fire and the brimstone and the
everything in this moment this sounds so
cliche is led by love
love love smiles you are gonna have to
let go of this fantasy it's gone right
your life took a left turn you didn't
expect it wasn't how you would have
drawn it up but it is what it is
now you gotta choose i'm gonna love this
grandbaby till
i'm gonna love this little baby like
she's never been loved before
and i'm gonna model for my son and his
girlfriend
what this kind of love looks like right
um everybody's got to be involved in
that way
if that grand baby goes to one of these
homes and
is is bathed in shame
bathed and we you shouldn't be here my
your daddy screwed up
man you are talking about legacy
changing shame you're talking about
family tree altering um
self-hatred and that baby doesn't
deserve that okay
so everybody's gotta be on the same page
as much as possible this is going to
mean that somebody and i'm
you called so i'm i'm appointing you
somebody's got to call a meeting
with the parents of these kids that
means you might have to get back in the
same room as your ex-husband or at least
get on a zoom call
that means her mom if dad's not
functioning then her mom's going to come
over
and you all need to come up with a game
plan and i'd recommend
six months to a year and then we're
going to reevaluate
it i i hate to tell you this your pets
come a distant distant distant
third number one to grandbaby number two
to your own kids
number three animals okay and if yours
is the only place these children can
help it can be together and they're not
going to be in the home
of an unsafe alcoholic and they're not
going to be in the home of
your ex-husband who for whatever reason
can't do it then that means you're going
to have to make some hard hard decisions
and you're going to have to make some
hard decisions not to regret not to
resent and not to get into that that
loathing cycle man this is all for this
little baby okay
all the focus here is on the future so
you're gonna have to help your son stay
involved with this child gonna teach him
how to be involved
he's gonna have to grow up real quick
and he also is gonna have to have
connection with other people
right and finding that balance is gonna
be so tough you didn't sign up for this
but it is in your lap
right and my guess is just how you just
explained the
her parents and your ex-husband this is
gonna disproportionately fall on you
so you're gonna have to be extra
intentional about self-care for yourself
whether you need to get a counselor
whether you need to get some friends in
your life that can help
if you gotta recruit some of your
buddies
from you know your local group or a
local church whatever that can
be on babysitting duty because you need
a break too this is going to fall on you
and what's going to happen is you're
going to start hating ex-husband even
more you're going to start getting
frustrated at her parents you're going
to start poking and grinding
and then suddenly the the the human
being that gets sacrificed at the edge
of that resentment is this little baby
okay
all right so you got to do whatever it
takes
to help your son and this young lady
graduate high school
because now you're playing a statistics
game and that is
if they don't graduate high school
there's a pretty clear trajectory
unless they become that one and a 5
billion person right
those things are going to be really
tough on them they got to go to high
school
and then they either have to go find a
local college that's close they can
continue this
or they're going to have to find a local
trade or whatever but the goal is
they've got to continue and finish this
education
it doesn't mean that their future is
over it means it's going to be way more
challenging out of the gate
and um getting everybody together
making a plan for six months and then
we're gonna revisit then the next six
months and we're gonna revisit um and
then the next six months we're gonna
revisit
we're just going to take it a semester
at a time or a year at a time a year for
a 17 year old is a thousand years right
you remember those days right
yes um so i'll tell you something that
happened when i was a
dean of students at a university had a
young woman come in
and she was pregnant was not part of the
plan
she was a young college student she came
in with her head held down
and she walked into our dean of students
office she was trying to figure out how
to take a leave of absence what she
could do because
and she just had this demeanor about her
that she was defeated
and i stepped i heard her talking to the
admin i stepped out and said hey come in
my office and she i said what's going on
she said well i'm pregnant and i cheered
i said you're gonna have a baby and she
looked at me and got wide-eyed
and i said no you didn't this isn't the
way you drew it up
but you're gonna have a baby and i i at
the time had a two-year-old i think or a
one-year-old three-year-old something
like that
and i just talked to her for a second
about this is the messiest
craziest most bananas adventure and i've
never
known love like i know right now with my
little bitty girl
and she just started crying and she said
something that was heavy she said
you're the first person to talk about my
baby
as as somebody to be loved her mom
called me later that night
earlier that evening and said i want to
thank you
for for challenging me like that
because nobody everybody has met my
daughter's eyes with how could you
i can't believe you oh my you did what
your life's over you're this
and her mom just said man i'd fallen
into that trap and so
thank you for reminding me i'm about to
have a grandkid right
is this gonna be so hard yes did you
want your son to grow up and go to
college and be in a fraternity yes and
be all silly and be goofy and then
you meet that your grandkid when he's 27
yeah that's how you drew it up and it's
not gonna happen that way
and so the quicker we can turn that dial
to laser in on
man we've got to be real specific about
what life's going to look like
real specific because you got kids
raising kid now
but also bathe everybody in love right
so when i say that how does that ring
true to you
it feels good you're validating that
it's okay to be happy
and excited about this i mean abortion
or adoption were never on the table and
so
um it feels good to know that i can
support them
and be happy about it um so
thank you for that well i thank you for
your heart and
i think it could be a lot of fun this
might be cheesy but
it could be a lot of fun because now you
can give parenting classes
you can give diaper or whatever putting
on and changing class whatever
you get to do something that i can
imagine many
many moms across history have wanted to
do which is
your son still lives in your house so
you can teach him how to
love the mother of his baby and you
could teach him what getting up at 3am
to get a bottle looks like and you can
teach him what not going to the movies
looks like
and you could teach them how to do what
cleaning bottles with those little
bottle scrubbers that were made by satan
what that looks like right all that
stuff because he has to
because he still lives with you right
right and you get to teach him what
honoring grandma looks like
and you can teach him what honoring that
little baby looks like
man so there's is this a is this a mess
there's no question and am i being
pollyanna about it yes
i am i know it's in store for you for
the next three four five six years and
it's hard
hard hard hard and you're going to be a
grandma
right there's this little baby that's
going to be about to show up
and it's going to be a disaster
it is you know it is yes absolutely but
mine was a disaster not this bad of a
disaster but mine was a disaster right i
mean i don't know anybody who's like oh
this is just smooth sailing way to go
everybody
so yes this is about love
love your kids love her love this little
baby is it a girl or a boy
it's a girl oh my gosh you're going to
have a granddaughter
right yes and you're going to get in
spit spittle fights with her
this young woman's parents you and your
ex you thought you and your ex-husband
fought oh man it's gonna be awesome
right right um but it's all for the sake
of this little baby it's all for the
sake of this little baby
so get an architect man get up somebody
who's going to help you map out what
this is going to look like
parenting classes every saturday for the
next the next two years right
high school class how can we get them
graduated quick get them into a local
community college quick
you may have to tell some of your cats
and dogs and chickens and frogs and
birds or whatever you got in the house
they got to find new homes because my
granddaughter's moving in
my granddaughter's moving in right and
be the first to volunteer tell the other
parents involved i'm going to let them
live here that baby's going to get to go
see mom
as long as she's safe in the home of an
alcoholic we're going to make sure
everything everything's safe
and then we're going to figure it out as
we go and make sure you take care of you
during this time because it's gonna be
tough because you're gonna be carrying a
lot of this load
i'm so grateful for you and for
every parent listening your kids will do
things
not as you drew them up they'll do
things not as you drew them up they will
they're gonna do stupid things they're
gonna do heartbreaking things you're
gonna do
mind-numbing things it's okay
to circle back to love every single
time every time every time